there's a lot more guardedness in this
camara both from the venture capitalists
and just I think the general public is
sort of you know been promised a lot and
it's starting to come to fruition my
sense is that this this dot-com era
isn't as Bowa isn't a bubble as as much
as the last one I can remember going
down the street in san francisco in 1999
i stopped at my corner grocer and i
bought an apple a granny smith apple and
on the apple was a little sticker and
normally that sticker says you know
produce from New Zealand and this
sticker said pets com go here to buy
your cat food and I was looking at the
sticker and I heard a sound above me and
I looked up and there was a blimp in the
air about 200 feet off the ground and it
was a pets com blimp and I realized that
we were in this really bizarre world
where the the internet had sort of taken
over and and the and the advertising and
and that being inside of a bubble were
up is down right is wrong gravity is
inverted is very stimulating for a while
but it's not sustainable that's not how
this feels and I think this is this this
internet phase that we're in is is is
basically delivering on the promises
that the first internet bubble made and
I think that's exciting i think the
internet is going to probably do
everything everybody claimed it was
going to do it's just going to take
longer than people wanted to admit at
the beginning and you know we still have
miles to go before we sleep not the
second coming of pets com but there are
companies that I that I feel like I I
just haven't there's no application for
me III don't I don't understand Twitter
because I that's just not the thing I'm
interested in doing I understand it's
interesting to a lot of people and I
sort of wonder you know what the sort of
longevity of things like that are they
just you know little mini fads and
they're going to be gone quickly the
there are these web 20 companies that
you hear about and you just think that's
a feature that could be part of a bigger
website but it's not really its own
standalone thing I think there's a fair
amount of that going on but the
fascinating thing about this phase of
the internet compared to the earlier
phase is that the amount of money it
takes this time to do a start-up is so
minuscule and I have a number of friends
who've done legitimate startups on 30
thousand dollars which they've done on
their credit cards or they've you know
done small friends and family rounds of
financing and so when the stakes are at
that level the innovation is so much
more because they're there isn't these
gatekeepers I think the venture
capitalists are absolutely in a panic
right now because that means that
there's less of a role for them out on
some of these smaller ideas now it
remains to be seen if any of these
smaller 30 thousand dollar startup ideas
are going to blow up and to become big
things but the economics of it have
changed and that's playing a pretty
powerful role in driving the innovation
that is at the heart of the Internet
you